περιπτώσεις που εσυζήτησε αυτόν το θέμα ξέρω ότι δεν είχε μπολούς που εσυμφωνούσαν ότι αυτό
επρεπε νακάνει αλλά ο ίτιος όπως είπαμε πριογούμενος είχε πάρει μία απόφαση την οποία ν
ηλοποίησες στο τέλος της ημέρας αλλάζουμε σε λίγα πάμε στον αντρέα σας συγραφέας ναι τρία
βιβλία δεν κάνω λάθος το τρίτορίτο είναιμετά τοπάσχααυτό θατι περιλαμβάνει των εωσοβλια το νέο βιβλίων
είναι μια έρευνα που αφορά το στης δεκανέα βους του τοχιλε νια ποχαι βδομή τα
τέσσερα είχε γίνει μία η πρώτη ανδιαμερικανική διαδήλωσης μετά την ισβολή στη λευκωσία στη διάρκεια
της οποίας εδολοφονήθηκε κατα μυστηριότη τρόπων ο αμερικανός πρέσμες στην κύπρου και λέω καταμιστηριόδην τρόποτι
ότι οπρέσβηση ήταν κλεισμένος μέσα στην πρεσβία του υ πρεσβία ήταν αποκλεισμένη τα παράθυρα και
τα παντζορια ήταν όλα κληστάρα δεν υπήρχε ορατότητα και η σφέρα που το έπληξε ν
διέσχισε μία περίεργη μπορεία σύντο ότι δεν ήτα μονομία ακολούθησε και μια δεύτερησφέρα που ακολούθησε
την ίδια περί που πορα και σκότωσηυν καιμίαν υπάλλιλον που εργαζότα στην πρεσβία δκινηδηνημέρ άρα
ήταν ένας μυστήριος φώνος ο οποίο στην μπορείαν δεδεν δεν εκαταδικαστκή μποτέ κανένας για το
φόνο καταδικαστεήκαν για μετάφοράνόπλον οχλαγωγία γκειολα τά και υπήρχε πάντα ένα μιστηρολυπήρχε μια θεωρία συνομοσίας
ότι μπορεί να των εκαθαρίσαν η διαμερικάνι που μας άρα έγινε να υτή η έρευνα
η οποία αν και στην αρχ δεν υποσχόταν ότι θα τφερνε πολύ συγκεκριμένα αποτελέσματα νομίζω
ότι είμαστε σε ένα σημείον που το βιβλίο θα μπορέσει να τεκμηριώσει ακόμα και επκή
ήταν πίσω από αυτούς οι οποίι ρίξαντε φέρα και τιτλος το εβλίο ότι τλος στου
ιβλίου είναι για ώρα της συνομοσία και πάμε είναι στο υπογραφείο είναι αλήμετα